[Music]
hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango indie movie guide and
welcome to my home you can tell I've
been away a lot because my plant is
almost dying but anyway getting into it
with my favorite of the week miss Steven
now this film came out in cinemas last
week but it's just now going to video on
demand you can watch it on Fandango now
this is the directorial debut of writer
Julia Hart and I want to see more from
her because this is one of those little
indie gems that sneak up on you
emotionally anything 0:26 but I think
you're older not because you look older
you just seem older it's about an
English teacher called miss Stevens
played by Lily rabe who some of you
might recognize from American Horror
Story and she takes three students for
an excursion to a drama competition what
do you teach
I mean English I teach it I'm an English
teacher I teach English do you have a
boyfriend seriously leave Rachel alone
Rachel whoa but of course this film is
not really about the drama competition
this is a great look at what it means to
be an adult I think a lot of people
could relate to this you know miss
Stevens is 29 she's about to turn 30 so
she's still quite young but she's old
enough to be this authority figure for
the kids she can't really be friends
with them or get involved emotionally
with them because she has to keep
herself separate the same time she's not
really ready to grow up as I said the
direction is really cool but the writing
is so solid as well because it takes
this twist and you think you know where
it's gonna go and it doesn't and I love
that plus the performances are wonderful
the kids are great and it's nice to see
Lily rabe out of that nun's outfit the
next film I want to tell you about is
called goat it's directed by Andrew Neil
I saw this one at Sundance earlier this
year and a lot of the press was about
Nick Jonas because he stars as one of
the characters in this film
i signal you gentlemen it's a frat boy
drama and Nick plays the older brother
to the main character Brad played by Ben
schnitzer and Brad is this very
sensitive guy he literally gets taken
for a ride gets abused feels ridiculous
about it feels like he wasn't man enough
to stop it so he decides to join his
older brother's frat now the Praetorians
have always fascinated me obviously
growing up in Australia we don't have
fraternities and sororities and I've
always wondered about this initiation
process welcome to hell we go you know
my friends here in America who were in
fraternities always talk about the great
Brotherhood and relationships that they
formed but that seems at odds with this
kind of humiliating initiation process
that sometimes they have to go through
this myself right they just do this to
weed out the weak ones this movie
obviously shows the more extreme
initiations I know not all fraternities
are like this but it's an interesting
window into a world that I don't know
much about if you're looking for a
documentary this weekend I want to
recommend the lovers and the despot this
is playing only in theaters at this
stage of probably in limited theaters
but it's well worth seeking out young
you should know soon enter tour improve
North Korean film business
this tells the unbelievably true story
of a really famous South Korean actress
who was kidnapped while in Hong Kong by
Kim Jong ill of North Korea you might
remember how Kim jong-il was a huge fan
of movies he had screening rooms in many
rooms of the house and he really wanted
North Korea to be as good at creating
movies as the rest of the world so he
kidnapped this South Korean actress and
then her husband who was a really famous
South Korean director went to Hong Kong
to try to find her and he got kidnapped
as well by North Korea you got could you
I was saying a little tapes of shin
talking with Kim jong-il now at that
time no one had ever heard Kim jong-il
say anything this movie plays like a
thriller like a mystery you are piecing
things together slowly it's chilling and
it's so hard to fathom two other
suggestions to watch at home this
weekend Swiss Army Man is one of my
favourite films of the year it's really
divisive
it's been called the fighting corpse
movie but I loved it it's so pulled a no
as they cast away and he befriends a
corpse he finds washed up on the beach
who's played by Daniel Radcliffe and
this corpse ends up being quite useful
now this movie actually has a lot more
heart than you may expect it's about
love it's about friendship it's about
this guy finding himself and loneliness
and the Daniels are interesting
directors it's not very often these days
that you find movies that feel holding
original that feel like they have a
unique voice and something to say the
production design is gorgeous the music
is really inventive the performances are
great give Swiss army man a go it might
not be a cup of tea but you will
definitely be in for an interesting
experience
the other film I want to mention to you
that you can watch at home from this
weekend is called my blind brother I
have just got to thank one individual
who is next to me the whole time I'm
running down that road there's this
voice telling you that you can do it
I of course in talking about God this is
a nice and quite funny movie about a
brother who was trying to deal with the
fact that his blind brother played by
Adam Scott is dating the girl that he
loved I liked seeing Nick Kroll as this
romantic lead he does a great job
Jenny Slade is fantastic and Adam Scott
is good at playing both the nicest guy
you'll ever meet and also the worst guy
you'll ever meet and then somewhere in
the middle with this character excuse me
do you mind trying to eat dinner over
here Rob he's disabled I'm disabled oh
my god the final film I want to mention
to you that's also out in theaters this
weekend is called the dress maker now
this is getting mixed reviews but it
might be just weird enough for some of
you to enjoy it it's directed by
Australian filmmaker Jocelyn Morehouse
it's based on a book and that stars Kate
Winslet as this Parisian dressmaker who
returns home to the Australian outback
and it's an interesting juxtaposition of
her wearing these very fancy glamorous
outfits in the tough rough outback I can
make you the most striking girl in the
room take your clothes and this being
it's all said in the fifties it looks
very beautiful but it's all very strange
there's a lot of moments that you're
thinking I'm not so sure where this
movie's going and it also stars Hugo
Weaving and Liam Hemsworth so it might
be worth checking out you could be
married in this suit snapped up by some
eligible spinster or Pegg trousers off
to yes so there you have it that's the
end of Fandango indie movie guide I know
I just threw a whole bunch of movies at
you but plenty of options for you to
watch this weekend let me know in the
comments below
are there any films you are looking
forward to have you seen any of them
what do you think of the show I want to
hear from you and also if you have any
questions about Indies about how they're
released about video on-demand
about what season anything you can think
of drop me a line on Twitter at Alicia
Malone and if I get a good question I
will answer it in next week's episode
until next time
[Music]
you